Welcome.
Hello, hello, welcome, welcome, welcome.
Howdy doody.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Thank you.
Hello.
Welcome.
To Steam Dolls.
Order of Chaos.
Yay!
Oh my goodness.
Guys, I'm so tired.
Okay, for those who watched Lifeline yesterday...
Um, and if anybody's watching this...
A long time from now, yesterday I played Lifeline.
Which is a voice command game from PS2 era.
And I played it for 8 hours and I was very tired at the end.
It was 7 and a half.
And it was a lot of talking.
And it was a lot of brain.
So today I was just like, maybe I don't know much about this game.
I think I'm gonna take it easy.
I'll have something, you know, kind of like...
So, first of all, I'm blocking it.
But this is early access build.
Not that I have early access, but...
Because I'm actually doing the demo.
Because I was just like, well, you know, I'm gonna try it out.
And also, um, I'm so tired today.
So I was like, I'm gonna take it easy after Lifeline.
And then I'm like reading stuff about this game and people are like...
Man, this game is pretty difficult.
It's like...
It's difficult.
It's like, um, you know...
It's kind of like, you know, higher level of difficulty.
And I was just like...
Oh...
But there's a reason I'm playing this game.
There's a reason I'm playing this game.
And it's because it was heavily promoted by and starring David Hayter.
As the main character, which if you don't know that name, that is Solid Snake from Metal Gear Solid.
And then also, there are other voices in this from Metal Gear, such as Christopher Randolph, which is Otacon.
And also, Jennifer Hale, which is...
I don't know.
But also, E.E.
So, yeah, it's very star-studded cast.
Star-studded cast.
But honestly, Jennifer Hale, she's such a great voice actress.
What's wrong with E.E.?
But, um, yeah, so I was just like, I'll check it out.
And so that's why I grabbed the demo, which is free.
But I want to say that just in case, like...
I don't know if this is like... It does say early access build, but the game is actually out now.
So I'm assuming that the game is the most updated version and that they have probably not updated this.
So if there's anything that is a little funky, then that's probably why.
And also, if you're like, why is she playing the demo version?
Um, well, I don't...
How do I explain?
If I really love the game, I will, you know, obviously go back and I will play the full version.
But I was kind of like, I just want to, you know, I read that the demo is pretty long.
So I was like, you know, I can at least get a feel for the game without...
Without committing myself to saying that I will complete the game on stream.
Yeah, we're testing the waters.
That's what a demo is for.
So, yeah, just as like an overall disclaimer.
Yeah.
But, um, I remember when Jennifer Hale was the voice of Gateway 2000 PCs.
At an early job, I heard her voice so often on hold with tech support.
What?
Also, Steven, thank you for the super chat.
Wait, what?
I had no idea.
I got my master's degree!
Master Paladin!
Thank you for getting me through all the down times during the past three years.
Minto, so happy I found you.
Congratulations!
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
That's awesome.
Nice.
Yeah, you're a master.
Sorry, I also meant to say, because I saw someone mention it.
When I say the demo is short, I put that in quotation marks because...
Someone said that someone in a Steam review was like, I got through it in two hours.
It's, you know...
I mean short as in like it's not, you know...
It is still a decent amount of time for a stream.
So I was like, you know what?
That's kind of perfect.
And me, knowing me, I always add like an hour to that.
I wonder how long the full game is then.
Are Steam dolls similar to ghosts?
Because they are made of steam and don't have a corporeal form.
What?
I'm not a doll.
Well, I could possess a doll.
Haunted dolls are like a hot thing.
You can go on eBay and find haunted dolls.
I feel like though...
If I, you know, stop VTubing, I might do that because...
What?
I just...
I just get to sit on a shelf all day?
So easy, right?
It's my birthday!
I was in Japan for my birthday last year, but I'm just old and boring this year.
I mean...
But at least I have Minto and David Hayter.
I don't think Minto is boring, right?
Sorry, I'm not Japan.
Happy birthday!
Wouldn't it be boring to sit there?
As a haunted doll?
Well, I'll... Okay, think of it like this.
You're sitting there.
You get free housing.
I don't have to... I would not have to pay rent or anything.
I would just sit there.
I would have a free show.
I would probably try to find, you know, someone that watches a lot of good TV.
And then I would just sit on the shelf and have free television every day.
And then, all I have to do is like...
Tilt my head a little bit.
Wiggle my arm.
Just give them a little bit of a show every once in a while.
And they'd be like...
Wow!
I might even become famous on TikTok.
I mean...
It seems like the easy afterlife.
Elf on the shelf.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But like...
Better.
Darch beans!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
So yeah.
Have people in the TikTok comments going fake.
No!
They would believe I'm real.
I'd be so convincing.
Steam dolls.
Is Gabe Newell getting into the doll business?
Yeah.
Steam dolls.
It's so cool.
Steampunk.
I feel like Steampunk is...
Like...
I feel it was revived maybe like a decade ago.
And then...
It's kind of a dying...
What's the word?
Style.
I feel as of recently.
Andregos, thanks for the 20 gifted!
Today is my birthday!
Having a slow day, working and watching Yoshi.
Jayth!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Jayth!
Happy birthday!
Might be an exhausted style.
I guess it was back in the 2010s, right?
Because it was a lot of places.
There would be Steampunk versions of like every character.
I feel at like conventions, you would see like...
Steampunk Star Wars characters.
Steampunk Batman.
Steampunk, you know?
There's Steampunk everything.
Actually, at the...
What's it called?
Tokyo Disney Sea.
Not Disneyland, but Tokyo Disney Sea.
There's an area of the park that is like Steampunk themed.
It's the area with the ride...
20,000 Leagues Under the Sea.
Oh sorry, that was my controller.
There's 20,000 Leagues Under the Sea and also...
Journey to the Center of the Earth.
I love Journey to the Center of the Earth.
Me too!
Oh my gosh, it's such a fun ride.
So awesome.
That was my controller disconnecting, but it's okay.
And...
The uniforms they wear in that area are pretty Steampunk.
They're very cute.
So I love going into that area.
I've never been a huge Steampunk person, but...
I can appreciate it, at least.
Steampunk Transformers figures coming out this summer.
What?
Is this the perfect time to get into Transformers?
Well, I don't know.
Is there a bad time?
Was there a bad time to get into Transformers?
Was it when the Michael Bay era was at its peak, maybe?
I quickly glanced at my second monitor.
I'm sorry!
Oh, nine months.
Time to take responsibility.
No!
I'll never take responsibility for any of my actions!
But thank you, Echoes.
Welcome back.
And Shallows, welcome back too.
Hello, Minky.
Would I ever play Bioshock?
I've never played Bioshock.
I don't know...
Actually, I don't know any spoilers about Bioshock either.
Is that a good...
I mean, I know it's a beloved series.
Would that be...
Something too...
Perfect?
Would it be something that you guys would be interested in seeing?
No one say anything.
No spoilers!
I managed to avoid spoilers for so many games and series and stuff because...
I think when, like, I don't know...
I hyperfixate on other stuff, right?
And so I hyperfixated on idols for a very, very long time.
And so I just...
I, like, you know, when someone's just like, how do you not see that on the internet?
How do you not just casually run into spoilers?
It's because I...
I very...
Like I said, I hyperfixate and I catered all of my everything that I would see to, like, idols.
For a very long time.
I'm such a mint simp.
My phone's wallpaper is now your Valentine's Day member's gift.
Every time I see a cute pic, I smile and I get so happy.
Thank you, Rodrigo!
Thanks for using it.
I'm glad you liked it.
If you are a member...
And you haven't seen the Valentine's Day wallpaper that I uploaded last week...
Check it out!
Speaking of idols, I went to Deer Stage last night!
Who was working?
Wait, I think my Oshi was working last night.
Did you see her?
Hot dog, indeed.
Oh, wait!
Went to Deer Stage yesterday for the first time.
It was so cool.
I didn't know any of the calls, but I had fun.
Thanks for the recommendations!
I also went to Jam!
If you happen to see my Twitter post...
Was your Twitter post the one about you going and then saying that...
Another VTuber had recommended it and then they drew on your coaster?
Thank you for joining!
Maybe.
I did see it then.
Anyway!
Shall we get into Steam Dolls?
I think you're gonna hear my...
There's my controller again.
Shall we try Steam Dolls?
I'm excited to hear the cast.
And...
It's gonna be weird.
It's always so weird hearing David Hayter in other games.
Like, there was that one...
Oh, gosh.
There was another, like, Metroidvania-style game that he was in.
I cannot remember.
But, like, it's always so, like, you're like...
Whoa, that's David Hayter!
Bloodstained!
Yes, I talked about playing it before.
Got the best news today.
My boss approved my four-day trip to Japan!
I'm so excited to get to go to your collab cafe.
Oh, my gosh!
Four days, though!
You're gonna be so jet-lagged.
Oh, unless you're very close.
Have a fun trip!
I like the thigh squish peeking at the edge.
Let's start.
New game.
Let me see how that...
My goodness.
Oh, I have a good feeling about this.
Okay, move.
Jump with A.
Attack with X.
Okay, I have to remember I'm not on a PlayStation controller.
Okay.
Jump, attack.
Raiden?
You can hear him.
Oh, I died.
Can I make it this way?
Nope.
Okay, they only want me to go this way.
Where am I going?
Nobody knows.
Oh, that's fire.
Avoid.
Can I double jump?
I cannot.
What the hell?
Did I get hurt?
Did I fall into the void?
What happened to the steampunk?
Suddenly it's so fleshy.
Oh, there's creatures coming at me.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my god.
I was just tapping them.
I wasn't even...
Oh, my god!
I wasn't even doing anything.
I just ran.
Again, this isn't...
Is that Christopher Randolph?
What are you doing?
Oh, so we were overpowered I think.
This is my tale.
I am the one recounting it.
I think it is.
Which, of course, means we are doing things my way.
Now, I should mention...
I am particularly fond of tutorials.
Tutorials.
So...
Oh, sorry.
Oh, my gosh.
I forgot that when I clicked out of the game.
Naturally.
I was moving myself.
We shall have to endure one now.
Okay.
To get it out of the way.
He's so dapper.
As for the journey ahead...
It could be sad.
Tutorial.
Or perhaps a bit humorous.
Or, frankly, it might turn out to be downright preposterous at times.
Life has a peculiar way of being all of those things at once.
Would you not agree?
I like the static noise.
It's kind of creepy.
Tutorial.
Oh.
Verifying installation.
Attempting reparation of the main database.
Success.
Utopic API.
Under the watchful eye.
100% done.
Run app build tutorial new version query.
Vault over obstacles with A.
Look at me.
I'm in the VR missions.
Okay.
Excellent, Snake.
Evade with R.T.
Oh my gosh.
I actually killed it.
Blasting foes will grant you blue spheres.
Look for them to re...
Wait, what do you mean blasting?
Oh.
While you were still press...
What is that?
Huh?
Blorbs?
What?
Key?
The bumpers?
While you were still press bumper.
Not that one.
Oh.
No, not that one.
Maybe both?
No.
LB.
LB?
Oh.
What?
I don't know what that's doing.
No.
It's the same thing, but...
What?
It's...
It's slightly different.
Huh?
Impressive whisper.
We can cut that.
So he calls us impressive wisp.
Good food from Otacon Daddy.
Wait.
It might be unbound.
Oh no.
Let's see.
Options.
Oh.
Can I not go to options?
Maybe...
No.
Oh, that's zoom.
Move.
But also D-pad is also move.
Wait, I...
Oh.
Huh.
Yeah, this is an early build everyone.
If you didn't see the very beginning.
I'll just kill him.
Sorry, I feel like the audio balancing is a little off.
Right after attacking, maintain X to charge a super attack.
Yeah.
Sorry if it's a little loud.
Huh.
Try bumpers?
I tried everything you guys.
Nothing is working.
Hold LT to...
Oh, that's what that is.
A snake.
Oh my god.
When the skull is visible, assassinate them with RB.
What?
RB.
I'll just keep turning it down.
Sorry, you can't hear the...
Oh wait.
If an enemy detects you, they will become way harder to kill and will trigger a global alarm.
Excuse me.
Wee woo.
Shoot.
I killed him.
I think the attack sounds are very loud, but the actual gaming sound is not so loud.
Global alarm prevents you from sneaking up behind enemies.
Your scrambler...
shuts it off.
Depletes the blue power gauge.
Is that what that is?
Okay.
Interesting.
Focus.
Wait.
Enable focus to get useful...
Oh, enemies or traps with a pulsing circle can trigger the global alarm.
Not all of them have this ability.
Be wary around the ones who do.
Okay.
Interesting.
And then it's RB.
Where is...
Let me kill him.
Oh, I'm so good.
What is that?
Oh, what the...
Use focus to follow the power lines effectively.
If a power line is interrupted, a wireless glyph can get you to the corresponding power line.
Why do I need to go to the power line?
What is that?
More than one power line?
Looks like the...
Wait.
Look at the wireless glyph and its letter to find the corresponding power line.
Oh.
A.
B.
Oh, I did it.
Thank you.
If you are low on health, heal with B.
Heal is a sub-weapon.
Collect sub-weapons by exploring.
Alright, I'm exploring.
Oh.
Okay, so we focus.
He does not have a thingy.
Gotta sneak up on him.
He was looking straight at me, but I still killed him.
Oh.
Destroy containers to get blue spheres or money!
What do we need money for?
Okay.
Pause the game to look at your map.
I did that.
Wait, what's down here?
Crouch?
Press A.
Okay, that's pretty standard.
You seem ready.
Shall we begin?
Okay.
Oh, oh.
The illusion of choice.
I'll do the second yes.
Yes?
Yes.
Excellent.
Okay.
I wonder who Jennifer Hale voice is then.
Oh, cutscene?
Every civilization has an expiration date.
After the Great Collapse, society was born anew in fear and loathing.
It was time for a change, but it never came.
It's different, I like it.
It's not the same.
Reprieve descended from the stars.
The discovery of a new power source to ensure the cycle never broke.
Boy, that's changed.
Humanity had once again failed to learn from its past.
But this time around, the most amusing thing happened.
The tumors of society began to spread in the flesh.
Despair coursing through their veins.
It becomes more and more.
Salvation will come from a different breed of evil.
Nothing will shatter my determination.
Whispering chaos and destruction as they sink into oblivion.
I don't know the story of this at all, but...
It's kinda cool.
Alright.
Much edge.
Very edgy.
We got our little blades too.
That was a nice speech.
Very moving.
Thank you.
It's like a weird Metal Gear where everyone's just a little bit off.
Everyone sounds just a little bit different.
He was listening to that?
That wasn't an inner monologue?
We were speaking that out loud?
Always listening.
Always yapping.
Please, someone...
Someone put that to Snake, please.
I need to know Solid Snake saying yapping.
I can't.
It's so good.
My doll that looks like you arrived.
The Doremi one.
Oh!
Wow!
I actually still... I have it... Actually, the tab's still open.
But I haven't ordered one yet.
I was just looking at it earlier today.
I was like, I want to get the blind box but I'm scared of not getting it.
He's a yapper.
That doesn't sound like...
Like that doesn't sound like David Hayter to me.
Or does it sound... Am I crazy?
It does sound like someone else.
I don't know.
I hear something over here.
It's loud.
They're drilling.
I like the setting a lot.
I guess we'll get there eventually.
What's that?
Oh shoot!
Sorry.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, these tanky men!
Ouch!
I died!
Oh my god!
How hard does he hit?
He needs more...
He's so beefy!
I took three hits and died.
Am I the worst assassin in the world maybe?
Don't see me.
Oh shit!
Come here.
And it said B to heal.
I see, I see.
Okay.
I wasted it kind of, but that's okay.
I was gonna sneak up on him.
Guy's got ears.
What is... What in the...
What in the... What was that sound?
What is this?
I got his ass!
Oh, we have the warning though.
Now we don't.
Wait, but he didn't have...
Oh, I don't think I looked in the right mode.
I looked in sneaking mode, then normal mode to see if he would alert everybody in the world.
I see, I see.
My bad.
Alright.
We look like grey fox a little bit.
That looks like a genome soldier, just straight up.
Excuse me?
And they have...
I don't wanna fight guns.
I'm just...
What the hell is that?
Oh my god!
The ladder animation is too funny.
Okay.
What?
That...
Oh gosh, okay.
Angry Roomba.
Dylan, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Wait, I'm trying to charge, but...
Oh, I broke it.
I don't wanna...
Let me test something.
Okay, I can run past it.
Angry Roomba.
That guy will sound the alarms.
Alarms.
I forgot about my free super chat.
Thank you for the free super chat.
Thanks for 8 months.
Are you kidding me?
You didn't hear me.
How did you know?
How am I supposed to sneak up on the guards?
Get your ass beat.
Maybe here, as I go down.
Okay.
Giving us all the little...
Wait.
These are things I can destroy.
I forgot.
There's...
I don't think I've seen anything else though that we can beat up.
Alright, we continue onward.
Sneak mode is something you can hold.
Yeah, that's actually how you do it, is you hold the left trigger.
Wow, that used up so much blue.
Lame.
I'm hearing a heartbeat.
You guys hear that?
That thing maybe?
Up?
Down.
Oh, game saved!
Got it.
Is that a wanted sign for me?
Sneakiest ghostman to ever sneak.
Oh my gosh.
It scares the heck out of me.
I'm destroying this family's home.
Oh.
Enable focus on glowing objects by pressing LB to hack devices.
What?
I'm hacking?
I'm hacking this chair?
Okay, I'm in.
Something doesn't add up.
Experiments!
Okay.
Nice.
There was... there's that door over there.
How... I wonder if the enemies respawn.
I guess we'll...
I guess we'll find out if they do or not.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And they do.
Alright.
There was like...
It was like down here.
How is... wait.
Unless hacking opened that door.
Let's go see.
If you exercise...
If you can exercise a chair, you can hack it, Minto.
Oh,
it did open this time.
Oh, sorry.
My big old head is blocking it.
Here, hold on.
I'm gonna move over.
I'm gonna...
Here, I'll put my...
Oh, there we go.
I'll like be a little bit off...
Off the edge.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm like constantly adjusting the audio.
My big old head.
Oh.
Music.
Ambience.
What's going on?
Oh.
Whoa.
Okay.
That thing is moving a little.
It's like chugging along.
I think it's struggling a little bit.
Okay, that guy will alert everything.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
No, no.
Hold on.
I'll wait for him to turn around.
Or come back.
Or do something.
Hello, sir?
Sir?
Oh.
Oh, I have a...
Chugging.
Chugging plus struggling.
I...
I just...
I have no excuse.
I'm gonna get him.
He's dead!
He's de...
Okay.
We're good.
Nice.
Holy cow.
Can I get two birds with one stone?
Nope.
Ouch!
Stop it!
I'm so glad this guy is deaf down there.
Is there anything up here?
Oh, just another guy.
Will I be able to sneak up on him?
Oh, shit.
Why do you have ears?
Sometimes.
Oh my god, I'm almost dead.
What was it?
B?
Okay.
The staff lounge closed before I could get lunch.
What?
No!
Slim!
Welcome to Mambushu!
Why does your name sound like an actual Metal Gear character?
Slim Thick Man.
Metal Gear ass name.
It's a reference, it is?
Come here, PNG!
Ouch!
I get hit by this thing every time.
Oh, okay.
We got it this time.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Alright, alright.
We're making our way down.
We're getting money.
Oh, this guy's got a pole spear!
You see him up there?
Oh no.
Okay, this guy I feel...
No, he can't!
Damn it!
I'm about to die!
Yeah, come and get me.
BB!
Welcome to Mambushu!
Thank you!
Stupid!
Think smarter, not harder.
Yeah, me!
Welcome to Mambushu!
Thank you!
Thanks guys for all the people joining membership.
I really appreciate it.
Anything down here?
Oh wait, this is where we started from.
Just kidding.
Thank you for the gift!
Thank you!
Oh, that's right.
We gotta go up.
I don't think I had to kill that guy.
And I did anyway.
I can either heal or disable the thing.
You know what?
Let's just...
I never expected to see anyone playing this game.
I like to play different stuff sometimes.
It's my birthday today!
I turned 30!
So I got laid off from...
No!
They did not lay you off on your birthday!
Oh look!
LB and RB work now!
Hold on.
Let's see.
Audio.
Let's do sound audio.
That should be better.
I'll even do master volume down just a little bit.
No!
That's so evil!
How do I say your name?
Pie chest?
That's so mean!
That's so evil!
I hope whoever fired you forgets to put the seat back down and they fall into the toilet.
That's happened to me before.
I was staying at my grandma and grandpa's place and I had to go pee in the middle of the night.
And my grandpa didn't put the seat back down and I fell in the toilet.
And I didn't notice because I was half asleep.
Is that how you died?
No!
Yeah.
It's a tough afterlife.
Anyway.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday and screw your old workplace!
Happy birthday pie chest!
Have I said your name right?
I hope so.
Anyway.
Back.
Ok.
I'm going to heal.
Oh B?
I don't have enough to heal.
YOLO!
Oh shoot.
I thought I was going down.
Oh shit!
We lived!
Everything is out to get me.
Nothing is safe.
Well I opened that door.
That's nice.
What's this?
I'm trying to go down.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
There is a guy here.
Can he see me behind... Ok.
Let's just... Wait.
Oh no, no.
There is another thing.
I don't know what I just did but...
Wait!
There is like literally a sign that's like...
By the way, human trap!
I still can't heal so we are going to...
We are just going to go for it I suppose.
He heard me jump?
What is this?
I wish I had a ranged weapon.
Like anything.
How am I supposed to...
I died.
No!
Oh, ok.
Can't aim up.
What a dummy guy, huh?
How is that for the sound though?
Does that sound better?
Than before?
Does it sound more ok?
Ok.
Must be a gamer.
We are going to kill this guy.
We did it before.
Oh, shit.
I did the wrong button.
No!
Well, it's ok.
We didn't need the health.
Hi Bito.
Does this game contain metal gears?
Oh, actually.
Actually.
Oh my gosh!
It did explode!
It didn't explode!
Just kidding.
Oh my god, I thought it did.
I thought it exploded it.
Oh, man.
Maybe if I jump in sneaky mode it will be better, you know?
So let's try it.
Ok, so that seems to be it.
I have to jump.
I have to perform the action in sneaky mode.
To ensure proper sneak.
Alright.
We are learning.
Oh no!
I forgot to open the wall.
I can't get back up.
Well, shoot.
So we will wait for this guy and we will try it again.
Activate your sneak jumps.
Come here.
Yeah, if only I had a wall jump.
I'm assuming we get money, so I'm assuming we can pay for like...
extra abilities and stuff in the future and other weapons and everything.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Enable focus.
Ok.
Oh, wait.
Oh, this was connected to...
Was I supposed to be on that?
It will come back down, right?
There it is.
Ok.
And let's go up.
Very cool.
LB.
Are these attached to nothing?
Nevermind.
Whisper is so cold.
Oh my god.
Is there fall damage in this?
Doesn't seem to be.
That guy was in my way.
That was so cold.
Yeah.
Very suspicious.
Why is this game got a sense of humor?
What is this?
I can't tell the...
The vibe of this game is so funny.
I can't tell if it's supposed to be so serious or not.
You know?
What does this do?
Nothing apparently.
Can't turn it on or off.
It's a good cheat...
Oh my god!
There's dead people in here!
What the hell is that sound?
What is it?
I'm gonna turn it up just a little bit.
Sorry.
Also look, we can get serious.
Oh yeah, see?
We can add abilities and secondary weapons and stuff.
Wow.
It looks like he looks like Slade from...
From Teen Titans.
Aki!
Welcome to membership!
We're not gonna comment on this?
No?
OK.
I'm afraid of what's going on over here.
What the hell is that sound?
OK.
Oh, it's this guy again.
We'll make sure he doesn't hear us.
Oh, maybe I'm too slow.
Oh gosh, I think I'm too slow.
Alright, hold on.
We'll wait for him to come back.
Nevermind.
I could've gotten him.
Shoot!
You missed a hundred... Oh wait, this is a LB.
Whoa!
There was a ghost!
I'm hacking?
Hack?
Wait, what was the button to hack?
Hack.
What's going on here?
Why is there a ghost in front of the door?
There's a lot of noise going on in there.
I don't think I like it.
The eye.
This room in particular looks very...
Oh sh...
Ouch.
I was going to say very Castlevania inspired.
No!
Dammit!
Game's haunted.
OK.
Oh my god!
There's two of them!
Yeah, come here!
Wait, sorry.
It was so loud again.
Sorry, I know I keep adjusting the audio.
I'm just trying to make sure we get it...
Maybe... I wonder if sound also includes voice.
No, that's so lame.
Alright, I'll just...
Anyway.
That's better.
Oh shoot.
OK.
Alright, and go!
Yeah!
Take your stuff!
OK.
Why enemy so dumb?
It's just how it goes.
Oh yeah, it says homeless hope.
What the hell?
Why is the homeless shelter in like a saloon font?
Excuse me?
Yeah.
OK, so we need to...
Oh my god!
I did the wrong... Wait.
Oh yeah, that's right.
You can't sneak.
You can't sneak while it's in a...
I got the nodges.
Homeless cowboys.
It's like the homeless baseball team.
OK, take the money.
Take more money.
We like that.
How do I... Let's see.
What haven't we explored in this area?
I feel like it's so quiet.
And I can't do these.
Oh wait!
Stay where you are!
Drop the gun!
Drop it!
Don't!
And that's how they died?
They both... They shot each other?
I guess... Sorry, you can barely hear the game at this point.
OK, let's go down.
Maybe this one.
What the...
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Alright, down.
Maybe down through here.
Oh wait, there's more.
What was down there?
Also, there's this.
A ghost man walking.
Oh wait, I think I can go down through here.
Aha!
What is this?
What the...
What...
Um...
What does that mean?
You can hear it fine?
OK.
Maybe it's just me.
I don't know.
Sorry guys.
I can't get the audio balance incorrect at all today.
I'm so sorry.
What does that mean?
Hello?
I think I have to like run in between.
Like that.
There we go.
Oh, is this the one we've been looking for?
No?
What one opens that door?
That is creepy.
Familiar voice actor?
Oh yeah.
You would know Adamska.
Woop!
Yeah, get him in a loop.
OK.
OK, this door is...
blocked?
OK, interesting.
OK.
I think we've killed like everybody in this place at this point.
Oh wait, I could have just gone up through here.
Whatever.
Alright.
OK.
This thing...
What?
What did that mean?
What did that do?
What do you mean?
Oh come on!
Enable focus to get useful information.
I'm not seeing anything useful about it.
What does that mean?
Useful information where?
Oh, it's probably... Oh I see, I see.
It's where the pipe goes.
OK.
Oh, it's a one hit wonder.
Easy peasy.
Oh, and it revives.
Oh my god.
Come here.
Alright.
Oh shit!
No.
Don't do this to me.
OK, run.
Alright.
Why are there so many of you?
Nasties.
OK, so... Oh my gosh.
Wait, we have to do like real math and stuff in this game.
To figure out how to open the damn door.
So fight!
OK, maybe not.
Maybe it's just like...
OK, so now we go to the next one.
Something screamed.
Wait, OK.
It's wireless through here and then it goes up.
OK.
How do I get up?
Oh, here we go.
Up.
Through here.
It goes to this one maybe?
OK, and then that goes up.
Maybe to here?
Yes.
It's got a lot to say, huh?
OK, now it's wifi.
Down, down.
Wait.
I'm not quite sure.
Math, it's so over.
It's so over for me.
The what?
We need to maybe look for more...
Oh,
wait.
That one...
There are so many lines!
Huh?
OK, this one is new, right?
This one.
OK, OK, OK.
And now it connected.
I wish I could go up.
Why can't you get on the bunk beds?
OK.
Alright.
So now it's that one.
Wait, I can go up through here.
There we go.
All set!
That's a great question.
OK.
Now we can go through the door.
Is there anything over here?
Look, we can somehow go up there.
Maybe we come back down through here.
Big brain Minto.
Alright, we are going to be that ghost man.
Oh my god.
OK.
I'm going to drop down.
I wish I could save.
OK.
Alright.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, I can't drop down there.
Oh my gosh.
OK.
Don't touch the walls.
Did I mess up?
Oh my god.
Heal, heal, heal.
Hello.
Who built this?
Why are there so much...
Everything in the basement.
Nastiness.
It's the last section of Lifeline all over again with like save points.
Yeah, but way less pressure in this, I think.
Yeah!
Game saved!
And it heals everything.
Oh my gosh, that's so nice.
Alright, perfect.
Wee-woo.
Is this a boss fight?
Oh, it's hell.
That's the guy over there, right?
Not me.
Eva.
It's Eva!
Eva 9000.
You should be more concerned by the fact that you are also organic matter.
Thank you, genius.
Excuse me.
Oh my gosh.
Ow!
How am I supposed to avoid that?
Maybe I just go around.
Ok.
Cool.
I wish I could see what the health is like on this thing.
What are those?
Oh!
Oh
no!
Get in the corner!
There is like no iframes in this game.
Maybe.
Oh no.
Ouchie, ouchie.
Ok.
Ok, ok.
Next round?
Maybe.
We are back to this.
Ouch, ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
This game is not very forgiving, huh?
I get it.
Come on!
Destroy!
Kill!
Did I get it?
I'm just going to keep going.
I'm not doing anything, but I'm going to go!
I don't think...
Yay!
First try!
So true.
Ok, yapper.
I wonder if dodging does give you iframes.
Maybe it does.
I don't want to reflect on that shit.
They are wrong here.
Not me.
His growl is like ASMR.
In my ears.
Anyway.
Is that a snake?
It is indeed.
Yeah!
Alright.
Bye Eva9000!
What is this?
I like his design so much.
Dash allows you to burst in the air with grace.
Such a majestic creature.
Ok.
Wait, can I like dash?
Wow, that's actually a lot.
Today is my birthday!
Shiromikan happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Shiromikan!
Happy birthday!
I don't know what...Oh!
It's this thing again.
Come back!
I wonder if we can get crushed by that.
That would be pretty silly.
Oh, that goes back down.
Every time I see one, I feel like I must trigger it.
You know what I mean?
Alright.
Oh!
Dead people.
More dead lab coats.
And more ugly things.
Trying to kill us.
Alright.
Woah!
Oh my gosh!
Back rooms!
What?!
I think I might be too slow crawling up them.
Ew!
He's like breathing and stuff.
Ok.
Alright, alright.
How's Matt Suitman?
Oh,
sorry.
Sorry.
Alright, let's get his ass.
Oh, just kidding.
And drop.
Slice and dice!
Artemis, thank you so much for the 5 Ginten.
Thank you.
What is this?
The aesthetic of this game is everywhere.
You got...you got...
Gross monsters.
You got...
What is this?
Nasty!
Oh no!
Oh my god.
What the hell?
Ok, so air boost only works if I'm in the air.
Got it.
Can I...was it only down?
Yeah, I think so.
Only down.
More dead people!
Oh gosh, these guys again.
Oh, they're so gross.
Oh, they're nasty.
I don't like the sound they make either.
It's so squelchy.
Ok, we can get this guy too.
Probably.
And drop.
And kill.
A solid plop.
Disgusting.
What the hell is that?
Oh gosh.
Ok, it's the same as that other thing, but with razor blades and also it explodes.
Like, it's the same as the other explodey one, but like, not.
Ok, so this goes somewhere, so we're just gonna flip the switch, baby.
Ok, alright, cool.
I wish it did.
You know how like in some games, when you like crouch down, it shows you what's below you?
So, that's something I feel that is missing from this.
You know what I mean?
Did I go over here before?
No.
Oh, we're fine.
Cool.
It's my birthday.
I started doing this bit where a phone conversation goes on too long, I start talking like a snake, like a codec call.
My mom called and is now really mad.
I think that's pretty solid.
But happy birthday, cat daddy!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear the cat daddy.
Happy birthday!
Ok.
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
I'm getting flamethrowered.
And he's still going.
Ok, bye bye.
No more alert.
Oh my gosh, imagine if there was a button in Metal Gear to just get rid of an alert.
Sounds amazing.
Sounds like a dream come true.
What is going... What the hell?
This place has gone to hell.
Nasty.
Ouch!
Gosh, they're so scary.
This one's not even moving.
Ok, very nice.
These guys are not bad, I just gotta be fast about it.
I think whatever they were experimenting on kinda messed up.
I think they made a... whoopsie.
Is this steam gonna hurt me?
No, it's called steam dolls.
Of course it wouldn't... Ok, now I'm lost.
This map is huge!
Oh my god!
Oh, ok, alright, ok, alright.
Ok.
Where are we?
Were we here before?
Nice.
I hope it exploded.
I don't wanna jump if I don't know where I'm going.
Ok, that's where I went.
I can't... I wish I could crouch down and...
That's where that goes.
Is death.
Oh my god.
That was so fast.
Alright, nice.
I'm gonna heal with the newfound energy we got.
Ok, very good.
Alright.
I don't know where we are guys.
I don't know where we're going.
But we're doing something.
Oh, wait.
We gotta save.
And, look at that.
Wait, wait, wait.
Sub weapon acquired!
Plasma knives.
Plasma knives can activate out of reach switches, but you can also use them as weapons of course.
Swap sub weapons by pressing or holding Y.
Wait.
Oh, I see.
It's up in the...
So, sub weapon I'm guessing is B.
Ok, got it.
Sounds like something Raiden would use.
Oh, that's where this leads!
Remember how I made note of this earlier?
Does it use... I think it uses my blue.
Ok, bye.
Anyway.
We're going back into the hell room.
Alright, we gotta go through all of this again.
It's ok, we'll go to the save point.
We'll get there.
I am like a cat with such quick reflexes.
Now, this part I don't quite understand how I get...
How I'm supposed to get over it.
I don't think I should air dash.
I will run into the other blades.
It's ok, there's a save right down here.
It's ok, we get our health and everything back right here.
Right?
Yeah.
Right here.
Yeah, alright.
Maybe they mean for that.
Alright, this is where we did the boss battle.
And onward.
Bad again.
And switch.
Bye, Eva.
Yeah, they just have a saw room for like no reason.
It's pretty exciting stuff.
Oh no, I'm gonna have to go through all the guys that I fought.
Again.
Isn't there a guy here or am I crazy?
No.
Here he is.
I don't know who's talking.
So, let's...
We need to go more up it seems.
Nasties.
Those guys are so gross.
I hate them.
We need to go...
Up, upper, up right.
Gross.
So here and here.
Did I do that?
No.
Oh no, I can't.
Oh man.
Ok, we'll figure it out.
You guys hear that guy?
He's cracking me up.
Oh shit.
Oh my gosh, he scared the heck out of me.
I think in here actually.
Oh yeah, there's this guy here too.
That's not making me very sneaky.
Dang it.
Ok, we'll just sneak down through here instead.
I keep hearing someone.
What was that?
Nice.
Ok, so...
That didn't go anywhere.
Map.
Slice and dice baby.
What do I... Where do I go?
Maybe I go back up?
Is there a way that I...
Who's talking?
They're really yapping at... Oh, here we go.
Really yappers up in here.
Maybe... Oh yes, I went to the left.
So here, we go this way.
Ok.
Alright.
Nasty.
Ok.
Good to know those explode.
Ok, cool.
Oh my gosh.
Ok,
that killed that guy.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Stop it.
Stop.
I need to follow it.
Can I follow it?
Down.
Ok, nice.
What's that?
Oh my god.
It's going to chop me.
I have to be so fast.
Oh golly.
Ok.
Ok,
we killed him.
We're fine.
Everything's ok.
Everything's fine.
I just ran into a guy on accident.
No biggie.
NBD.
No big deal.
There's nothing over here?
Who built this?
Ok.
Grab some more money.
Come here.
I'm trying to bait you.
Oh, you're stronger than the others.
We're fine.
Everything's good.
Ok.
Alright.
Where are we?
Who?
Oh, that guy?
Yeah.
Ripperoni.
Joe built a decorative saw.
This area is huge.
Also, this demo is huge.
There's so much going on.
Oh no!
I forgot.
Wait, how do I...
Why?
Ok, now we can yell.
Ok,
this works.
The elevator.
Was there anything over here?
Nope.
I forgot it's a demo.
I know, right?
It's so long.
I told you guys.
Nasty.
That one?
Ok.
What does that do?
Oh, switch.
Ok.
Now that should go...
What does this one do anyway?
I don't know.
Anyway.
And this way is blocked by an evil branch.
Ok.
We love to see it.
And now this one's powered on.
Ok, we go up.
Oh, it gives you blue?
No way.
So I can get rid of the thing.
I should've...
I should've farmed.
I'm an idiot.
Oh, cutscene.
Hello.
Hold your fire.
I don't understand the story at all.
There are always complications.
Am I gonna have to fight all these guys?
Or...
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Stop a bad...
Oh,
the ship has eyes.
I'm running.
Do you actually want me to run?
I'll run.
Here I go.
Oh, shoot.
We're running.
Ok, we're running.
Oh my God.
Dang it.
There is no music.
I'm wondering if maybe there will be some music in the final version of the game.
Oh my God!
No!
I did it again!
What the...
Oh gosh, ok.
She's in pursuit, you guys.
That's what I...I don't know.
She will if I can manage to get past this.
I'm not gonna chase...
chase platformers.
No!
My timing!
She's standing down.
I mean, no.
She's in pursuit.
Oh my God.
Guys.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm really not good at scenes like this.
Next week.
Ok, nice.
Oh my God!
I
got killed mid-combo.
I got killed mid-combo.
Pieces of you next week.
She really does like the sound of her own voice.
Ok.
This game is very sassy, yes.
Oh you know.
Ok.
Have a little faith.
Down?
Wait.
Oh, down.
Oh my gosh, I can't see anything.
Actually, I think there is music.
I think it's just very quiet.
Pieces of you next week.
She really does like the sound of her own voice.
I know.
He knows!
He knows.
Oh my gosh.
We made it!
No we didn't!
Oh my God, everything is going down.
Everything is going down!
Ok, we are fine.
Enough already.
Explosion.gif?
We made it!
I think.
I hope.
Enough already.
Oh!
Did I really get through the demo?
Is that it?
I did it?
I got through the demo maybe?
Title drop?
Am I a gamer?
Oh my gosh, someone said it took them two hours to beat it.
Someone said...
What?
Geronimo!
Welcome to my voice chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for joining.
I was short.
It ended up being so much shorter.
Took me just an hour and a half.
And then I also yapped at the beginning.
I think I'm too much of a gamer.
That's it.
I'm too strong.
That was fun though.
Let's see.
Steam dolls on Steam.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, I was on Duck Detective earlier.
Duck Detective has a new game called Duck Detective the Ghost of Glamping.
And I was like, ghost!
That's me!
So, I was looking at it on the Steam page earlier.
You're more of a gamer than you realize.
It's true!
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
Wins Duck Detective.
You guys want to hear?
Hold on.
I'll share my Steam.
Give me a second.
We can watch the trailer for Duck Detective.
Steam.
Let's watch Duck Detective together.
I've always been drawn to mystery and misery.
Like a duck to water.
He's a duck.
Do you guys remember the first Duck Detective?
Oh, he's back!
And you have a sidekick.
The little gator guy from the first game.
She's vain because she has perfect skin.
That just means she has...
That just means she has good genetics.
Beware of the ghost!
The ghost!
Duck Detective.
The Ghost of Glamping.
Wasn't the gator a big fanboy?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, he was.
I'm also kind of offended.
I said I wanted a voice act in this game.
I feel like I could make a wonderful character of...
Somebody.
No one left.
What does that say?
Keep...
Something fried.
Cinderathalos!
Thanks for the five gifts!
Yeah, wait.
So Steam Dolls VR.
No, no.
Is there a VR?
For VR?
No way.
Is it the same game?
What's happening?
What is this?
Is this the same game?
I can't tell.
It has like the same logo.
It has the same logo, so I'm confused.
I thought that was Vamp.
Oh gosh.
Oh my god.
It does look like Vamp.
And you have Ariel.
The graphics are... I don't know if I would want to see those in VR.
How does this...
Oh yeah, it's the dev the same.
Let's see.
To the sky, dear.
I love this song!
What's it called again?
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I love that song.
I used to listen to that song all the time.
Wow, that's such a throwback for me.
Order of Chaos.
Ok, here we go.
The Shady Gentleman.
It is the same.
Johnny Bronzehand.
What?
Devon Chott?
Wait, where?
Hello?
I just finished the demo.
I had so much fun.
Well, thank you!
Hello, dev, if you are here.
Hi.
I couldn't find you.
Where are you?
I don't know.
Thanks for the buy gift!
Wait, let's see the trailer for the full game.
Oh, as designer of Order of Chaos, I was not involved in the VR demo.
Hello!
Thanks for dropping by!
We just finished the demo.
The atmosphere is great.
It looks so fun.
I mean, it was fun.
It looks so...
So meaty.
Jennifer Hale is in this game?
Yes!
That's what I'm saying!
You got David Hayter, you got Christopher Randolph, you got Jennifer Hale.
It's such a star-studded cast.
What was that?
I like that this game even has cutscenes.
That's so insane.
This song is a bop.
Very cool.
Thank you for the good luck.
I cleared... You cleared what?
Of course!
Congrats?
Thank you, Brie, for the superchat.
Clap, clap, clap, clap.
Oh yeah, we were in... Actually no, we did do this part.
I killed that guy.
Well actually I think I landed on his head and then I...
And then I beat him up.
Everything is so icky.
In a good way.
I mean it's supposed to be icky.
Wow, yeah we saw this.
What?
What is going on in this game?
What is happening?
Wow.
I like that it is a stealth... It's interesting to have a stealth metroidvania game.
Exploration, stealth and blood.
We are really proud of it.
Still working hard during the early access.
We are two on the dev so it's a lot of work.
Oh my gosh, you guys are cracked.
Well, good luck with everything.
Wow, two man team.
Sheesh, and this is what it looks like.
Two man team and this is how it looks.
What the hell?
How did you end up getting David Hayter and Jennifer Hale and Christopher Randolph?
I had a lot of fun.
Again, I didn't think I mentioned this at all.
I don't think I felt like I really needed to mention it.
I'm not sponsored or anything to play it.
I just wanted to play it because, you know, I was honest.
I was like, you know, Metal Gear voice actors are in the game so I'm going to play it.
Obviously, these are my real opinions.
Without any money backing them.
Raymac, thanks for the 5 gifted.
That was very obvious.
Well, I just want to say, you know, just anything.
You know, some people might be like, oh, she's only singing praises.
She must be sponsored.
Getting the cast is just a try that succeeded.
Wow.
That's so awesome.
Are you guys fans of Metal Gear 2 then?
Sorry, I'm really Metal Gear brain.
But I played this and it was really awesome.
I will buy it.
Oh, and it's on sale.
Look at that.
Oh, Valentina.
I wonder if that's Jennifer Hale.
Yeah, I did that.
That was me.
I did that.
Yeah.
Hacking skills.
Oh, I like that actually.
I think that's really cool to see like the hints.
And to see like, oh, go this way with the little ghosties.
I call small dev indie games penny stocks because you might strike it rich.
Oh, when you strike it rich, you really strike it rich.
Sometimes though, they do flop.
That's just the nature of the games though, right?
Even, even triple A titles flop.
So, you know, I just like games.
I just like game.
So I think it's fun to play game and to try all sorts of game.
And that's why I was like, I'll try something new today.
Because, you know, probably many people might not give this a chance, you know?
So, why not?
If I can even get one extra person to check it out and, you know, be interested in it.
Controversial opinion.
Yeah, I know.
I'm full of those.
And I like platformers.
I'm always wanting to get better at platformers.
That's always one thing that I'm like, you know, I, I, yes, would like to get better.
Oh, so that was Jennifer Hale as Stella.
You will encounter a flamboyant cast as you traverse the game.
A goddess of nature.
A rich immortal who wants to die.
A female gunslinger with deadly aim.
And others?
Who's to say?
Oh, Joy Princess, thank you.
And Yanmei, thank you.
The aesthetic is cool and unexpected.
From the title, I thought it would be, it would look like Alisa.
A horror game where the currency is metal gears.
No way.
Enemies.
I can't believe it has cutscenes though.
Games like this rarely ever have cutscenes.
But yeah, platforming is always like something that I like.
But it's, it's, you know, it's like, like Celeste, you know.
The, you really got to build up in terms of, it's, I feel once you get good at platformers, it really helps with your, what's the word?
Your reaction time and things like that.
So, I'm always, I'm always wanting to do that.
Look at these.
What is this?
This looks cute as hell.
It's a Doom?
Wait.
It's anime Doom?
Wait, I've seen this before.
I have seen this before.
No way.
I have seen, what?
I have seen this game before.
It already has a sequel.
I didn't know that.
Six episodes and 30 levels.
Yeah, yeah, I remember this trailer.
I remember watching this.
I thought I added it to my wish list.
No, I guess not.
I'll add it, I'll get it later.
I...
What else is here?
Frog gun.
Dang, there's a ton here.
The Guro game.
What?
Citadel?
What is?
Is it really?
It's a tad Guro.
Maybe YouTube won't...
Maybe that's why I didn't get it.
Ero Guro.
Maybe YouTube will get mad at me.
I don't...
Okay, this might be a...
Sorry, that was my controller disconnecting.
This might be a controversial opinion.
I'm typically okay with Ero Guro.
Or rather, like anime Guro.
Because it's...
It's the same as like anime horror.
It just...
It feels very...
It's like not...
Like, it's...
I can very...
I can very much take myself out of it.
You know what I mean?
It's 100% not real.
So it doesn't get to me as much.
Yeah, it's cartoony.
Exactly.
I grew up on Corpse Party YouTube videos too?
You grew up watching Corpse Party?
I grew up playing the heck out of Corpse Party.
I...
Oh my gosh.
I played so much Corpse Party.
You watched it.
I lived it.
In my death.
Mhm.
You weren't allowed to get it.
Oh no.
Corpse Party on Yume Nikki Bros.
Corpse Party on which platform?
Okay, I didn't play the original PC-98 one, if that's what you're asking.
But I played the...
Oh gosh.
Uh...
What's it called?
Hold on.
Um...
Corpse Party...
PSP?
Was it that one?
Like I played...
Oh.
Which one?
I did play Book of Shadows.
Do I remember much of Book of Shadows?
I don't.
Hold on.
I'm researching.
Mhm.
Oh, why did it go black?
That's weird.
The one...
Okay, so there's like...
Here.
I'll show you guys.
Okay.
There's...
Actually, no.
I'm pretty sure.
I think actually...
No.
I...
There's this art one.
Of...
For...
Why did I just open that?
There's this art.
For Corpse Party.
And then there was the original art.
But I played this one.
Now that I think about it.
I did not play the original art one.
Which was this one.
Which is so peak.
Look at that.
It's so good.
Yeah, yeah.
So the PSP one.
Okay, okay.
I thought it was the PSP one.
Look at how peak that is.
It's so good.
Memories.
But I think I watched a playthrough of that one.
Maybe.
Because the art is just too good.
Anyway, yeah.
Obligatory butter up my pooper reference.
Yep.
That's the game where butter up my pooper came from.
Sometimes localization really just hits in the right way.
Don't you think?
Anyway.
This is Flynn.
It's a bit of a shorter stream.
Actually, it's a much short stream.
Not even two hour stream.
Let me put on some music.
Since we're just kind of talking in the...
Talking in the...
In the...
Silence.
BGM.
There it is.
Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
We could go to the cafe.
You wanna go?
We can go for a little bit.
I'll hit two hours.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You deserve a break after all that lifeline.
I know.
I was like, you know...
That's why, again, I was just like, I'll do the demo.
Because I will be able to...
Say, hey.
Stop.
After this amount of time.
Book of Shadows was the point and click one, right?
Was there point and click?
Yes.
It was like mostly visual novel.
Oh gosh, it's been so long I don't remember.
Right eye.
Left eye.
Red stomach.
Red eye.
I think, I think...
Those phrases will be stuck in my brain for a whole eternity.
If you don't mind us asking, what's the story behind Punishment?
Um...
If I tell you, I'll have to kill you.
Do you really wanna know?
Do you really wanna know the story behind Punishment?
Yes?
Okay.
Um...
Oops.
I...
Felt like it.
That's it.
Yeah.
I've said...
I've said, I wanna make a Metal Gear reference on my profile.
But what can I do?
And I was just like, I feel if I say naked mint, it's kinda weird.
Hot dog.
Oh, Bloodstained, yeah!
Pepman, we talked about that earlier.
Oh, thank you for the donut.
Um, I was like, if I put like naked mint, it might be kinda weird.
And solid mint.
I was just like...
Unfortunately.
For like...
Metal Gear.
Venom is just so recognizable.
Even though he's not even my favorite guy.
But Punished Snake is like...
Everybody...
You've seen that and you're just like, oh yeah.
That guy is Punished Snake.
Especially in photos and everything too.
I love coming back to big head minto.
Big head?
I should've done old mint for authenticity.
Gezora!
Why are you so rude?
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna become...
I'm gonna go goth for that.
Oh, my arms.
Oh my god, that's awkward.
Don't look.
My arms.
Is this Punishment or Punished Mint?
Then I say yes to both.
Goth.
Hold on.
Oh, wrong button.
Dark.
What was I gonna say?
No, I don't wanna show you guys that yet.
I don't wanna show you that yet.
There we go.
Minto, will you play Peace Walker PS3 or 360?
Also, do you have any tips for a noob wisp?
Tips?
Like, ghost tips?
Ghost tricks?
Ghost tips and tricks?
Oh, I don't know yet actually for Peace Walker.
What we'll do.
I have to see if 360...
360...
I wanna play on 360.
I have to see if servers and everything are still up.
Ghost trick?
I feel like I should've worn...
I should've been in this mode for...
for the stream.
Because it's...
It's so much more fitting of the setting.
What about portable ops?
Maybe...
Someday.
Maybe someday I'll play portable ops again.
Way down in the future.
Will JP Mint be streaming?
No, unfortunately.
I'm sorry.
My schedule is becoming more and more packed.
As I get closer.
So, for those who don't know, I'll be going back to Japan...
next week.
And if you're like, But, but you just got back from Japan.
Well, if you didn't see the cafe announcement...
I'm going for the cafe.
I got stuff I gotta go film over there.
And...
It just aligns with other stuff.
Hot dog.
Minto cute.
So, and then there's also something else that...
completely unrelated...
that might've been added to my schedule, so...
I'm only gonna be there for like a week.
So, I have a lot to do...
in just that little bit amount of time.
But, after that...
After this trip, I won't be going back to Japan...
until a while from now.
So, you'll have me for a couple months.
Until I have to go back, but...
I go back for some other cool stuff.
I go back...
All my Japan trips that I have...
scheduled at the moment are all for work.
So...
You said that before, but okay.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
This time, it's true.
I only have one thing scheduled.
Well, two.
But, yeah.
Your outfit is so cute, just like you are.
Thanks, Rodrigo!
Isn't it a good thing that I'm going to do cool things, right?
And then you can be like...
She's doing that thing!
How exciting!
But, you know...
And not everything is like the cafe where it's Japan only.
Wink, wonk.
So...
Yeah.
Busy, busy.
Busy, busy for content.
Have you ever been to an IRL goth maid cafe?
Yes, kind of.
It was like...
Kind of horror-themed, but they were dressed gothy.
Will you be allowed to take pictures or video of the cafe?
Me or people going?
I...
I'm not quite sure for myself.
I would like to.
I'll try.
But people going, of course, 100% can take...
Can take...
Photos and video and everything.
It's the same cafe that...
Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky...
Yeah, the cafe allows it.
I won't be able to go to the cafe, but I hope you have tons of fun in Japan, MitoQ.
Thank you!
It's the same cafe that Ayami Mama did...
She did a collab at last year.
And actually, Kiara went and she took a video.
And it's on her channel as a short.
So if you go to her shorts...
Cute!
Thank you!
If you go to her channel, you can go see it.
I actually took some video, too, of one that I went to last time.
So I might actually edit it.
And then I can...
Last time I went to Japan, Pandomimi...
If you know that artist, she did a collab cafe at the same place.
And...
I went.
I went on the very last day.
And so I can probably be like, this is what it's like.
It's not a very big cafe.
But I don't...
I don't know, honestly, how many people will be going.
There might be reservations required, but...
I was able...
No, I did have a reservation for that one, but...
I mean, I'm not super popular in Japan, so...
So...
Probably not a ton of people will be going for me.
But...
If you decide to go.
So...
We'll see.
Me domito.
That's me.
Sorry I can't go.
Why are you apologizing?
I'm not...
You can't go to a thing that's in an...
Probably in an...
Or possibly in an entirely different country than you.
It's very expensive to go.
At that one?
I've only been to Ayami and Panomimin, so...
Only those two that I've been to.
So Ayami.
Not a lot of people are going to go for me.
Okay, but...
I said because I'm not popular in Japan.
I do not know.
Yeah.
So I'll be gone for about a week.
And...
You know, just think of it as like a...
But I probably will do the 24 hour...
Stream stuff while I'm gone too.
So, you're gonna have that plan if you need any Minto in your background noise.
Do you just get a reservation off their website?
I've only ever gone to cafes without them.
Yes, I think so.
I think I got it off their website.
Before.
And it's not like...
It was pretty easy.
For the... Okay, so...
For Ayami, I didn't have a reservation and I was just able to go.
They do have a kiosk outside of the cafe.
That you can put in like your name and stuff.
Or you can reserve online.
And...
When I went for Pando Mimi, I reserved online and then I went.
And I like walked inside.
I was like, hi, I have a reservation.
And they were like...
They didn't even check it.
Oh wait, no, they did.
They did, but they also had like complete tables.
Or like empty tables.
So, I think I could've just gone in anyway.
What if you had a 24 hour looping stream of raging against Naomi?
I like ranted for like 5 minutes.
You want that for 24 hours?
That's...
Sure is weird to apologize for things you don't need to, right?
I don't wanna hear your sash.
Oh wait, oh my gosh.
What if I make my bangs longer?
Wait, it goes so well with this outfit.
I don't wanna hear your sash.
Going to Japan afterwards, so I can't go.
Have a great trip!
What about your Lifeline song mix?
If you don't think of something quick, I'm gonna die here!
Die here!
Oh man, I hate how much this game has...
How much we're gonna be referencing this game for a while, I feel.
No!
Let me forget about it, please.
I already... I'm a ghost.
I already have so many regrets.
No, I don't regret playing it.
It was fun.
It was fine.
An instant stream classic.
Unfortunately.
We're trauma-bonded, it's true!
Oh, it's so true.
Okay guys, I'm Eepy.
I know it's a very short stream today.
But thank you for a short stream.
We can do short stream every now and then, right?
Especially if I do long stream.
So some people can have something to catch up if they wanna, you know, something short to keep them...
company in the background.
Okay guys, I had fun.
And I will see you guys when I see you next.
Which...
Tomorrow is supposed to be a collab.
But I think Doki is also not feeling well.
And Lime is not feeling well.
So...
If both of them are not feeling well tomorrow, Then I will switch Henry Stickmin.
And they said that we'll maybe do it Thursday.
For...
The collab.
So hopefully it will still...
It will still...
Happen this week.
She's playing Marvel Rivals.
I mean, I'm just telling you what she said.
I don't... I don't... I'm not her mom.
If she's sick, I'm not gonna say...
Hey, stop streaming.
Like, that's... She's an adult.
She can do whatever the hell she wants.
That's not my business.
But if she feels sick even worse after streaming...
Then...
I don't know what to tell you.
Hello!
Atsumi doll!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Right now you look like...
One doll I had as a kid called Mira.
That my little brother used to be scared of.
One day a bird took her?
What kind of birds do you have in your country?
Doki's unwell.
Doki's playing Marvel Rivals.
Why wisps repeat your words back to you?
Right?
Right!
Okay, thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
See you guys later!
Bye bye!
Okay, bye bye.